-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
This is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
That is so good to hear.
Let's get to the news.
President Biden on Saturda
played his first round of golf
since becoming president,
though he has picked up hi
driver a few times this year
but only to stop his dog Major
from attacking a staff member.
Get behind me!
Everybody get behind me!
That dog's got some Scranton
in him.
That's right, President Bide
played his first round of golf
since becoming president,
which weirdly,
is weirdly what made it
finally hit home for Trump
[ As Trump ] Oh, my God.
He is president now.
[ Normal voice ] All U.S. adults
are now eligible
for the coronavirus vaccine.
Not so fast,
Senator Kyrsten Sinema!
They're probably gonna card yo
if you keep dressing like
a three-episode character
from "Square Pegs."
Baze with the "Square Pegs" ref!
[ Laughter ]
Long-time --
Yeah, keep him in darkness
The Pegs Heads like
to keep it anonymous.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughing ]
President Biden over the weekend
attended the confirmation
of his grandson,
but then Mitch McConnell sai
it's too close to an electio
and put all confirmations
on hold.
Former President Trump release
a statement yesterday
praising
President Biden's decision
to withdraw U.S. forces from
Afghanistan and called it,
quote, a wonderful and positiv
thing to do.
Which makes a lot more sense
when you find out
he's joined the Taliban.
Allegedly.
House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy said recently
that though Florida
Representative Matt Gaetz
is under federal investigation
for sex trafficking,
Gaetz will not be removed
from committee
and is, quote,
innocent until proven --
Oh, really? On Venmo?
Wow, just right out there?
Still, I think
we should wait and --
That's him there? Oh, boy.
You guys are making this tough
Senator Bernie Sanders
and Representative
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez today
unveiled the Green New Dea
for Public Housing Act,
which should keep Fox News bus
until "Danier" Tiger comes out
as gender nonbinary.
I think I mumbled it.
It's Daniel Tiger.
-Not Danier.
-So, you know, save the --
save the e-mails.
[ Laughter ]
I knew what it was --
it's a flub.
A flub is different
than a mistake.
[ Laughter ]
Yesterday was
National Transfer Money
to Your Daughter's Account Day
This according to an
increasingly suspicious calendar
your daughter got you
for Christmas.
"BTS Appreciation Day"?
A dozen of the top
European soccer clubs
announced over the weekend
that they will leave
the Champions League
and form a new breakaway league.
Fans said they were hurt
by the move,
but 10 seconds later,
they were fine.
That's a very niche observatio
about soccer,
about soccer injuries,
from Ian.
NASA today
successfully conducted
its first controlled fligh
on another planet
and then immediately flew it
into their neighbor's yard
[ Chuckles ]
Federal regulators on Saturday
issued an emergency
safety warning
for Peloton's Tread+ treadmill
The warning reads, "Do not get
this for your wife
unless she explicitly
asks for it."
Two intoxicated men in Franc
recently injected hemorrhoid
cream into their genitals.
But they're still not sure about
getting the COVID vaccine.
[ French accent ]
I have read some things.
There is some, eh,
troubling data.
[ Laughter ]
Is there any more
hemorrhoid cream?
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] And finally
according to research,
waking up to your favorite son
can make you feel
more alert and less groggy
It will also, in a week,
make you hate
your favorite song.
And that, everybody,
was a monologue.